we've searched the property and we've
located seven bodies Oklahoma law
enforcement found those bodies in
Henrietta Monday but would not discuss
any additional facts of the case there's
no suspect at large that we are looking
for right at this moment while neither a
motive nor the name of a suspect has
been released the father of 16 year old
Brittany Brewer confirmed his daughter
was among the dead she always played
with her little sister and and I don't
know how I'm gonna tell her because
she's like Britney's law Britney's
missing Britney's missing and I gotta
tell a four-year-old that she's gone and
I don't even know how to do that earlier
in the day Oklahoma Highway Patrol
reported Brewer was endangered and
missing along with her friend 14 year
old Ivy Webster they were believed to be
traveling with 39 year old Jesse
McFadden